if you thought things were already bad
for beleaguered republican congressman
matt gates
they are getting a hell of a lot worse
and the pressure is truly building on
the republican party to do
something about his continued presence
in the house of representatives
here's the story joel greenberg who's a
major player
in this investigation that looks at
whether matt gates committed
all sorts of different crimes including
possibly trafficking
underage girls joel greenberg wrote in a
letter
that has been obtained by the daily
beast that he and matt gates paid for
sex with multiple women
including a minor girl 17 years of age
at the time in question
the letter was drafted after greenberg
asked roger
stone a close ally of trump remember
for help obtaining a pardon greenberg
wanted
stone to help him get a pardon from
donald trump at the very end of donald
trump's term
greenberg wrote in the letter quote on
more than one occasion
this individual was involved in sexual
activity
with several of the other girls the
congressman from florida's first
congressional district
and myself from time to time gas money
or gifts
rent or partial tuition payments were
made to several of these girls
including the individual who was not yet
18 years old i did see the acts occur
firsthand this is a first-hand witness
and venmo transactions
cash app or other payments were made to
these girls
on behalf of the congressman this is
a bombshell blockbuster alleged
first-hand claim
now understand that for some time now
we've suspected that this specific
allegation was going to come out
why well when we learned that this joel
greenberg decided to cooperate with
investigators
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller held a
hilarious
press briefing right outside a
courthouse and was asked straight up did
your client joel greenberg introduce
matt gates to underage girls check out
the then
hilarious but ominous response from
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller
did your client introduce nat gates to
any underage girls
or secularly
all right so i'm just going to let you
sit down there and so i can look over
your head
and ignore that question
i apologize i i just can't answer that
question i wasn't okay
that was that was a little devious you
hiding down there below and
you zing that at me you know
okay so anybody who sees that is
immediately thinking
that really sounds like something we
should be looking into that's the
furthest thing from a no that i could
imagine
and indeed now this letter obtained by
the daily beast written by joel
greenberg
allegedly says exactly that matt gates
and i paid women for sex
one of those women i know was a child
was an underage girl
17 years old now for me this is not
really about prostitution
there's an important and prescient
conversation to have
about sex work and whether there should
be legalization decriminalization
regulation of sex work for the safety of
the service providers
this is a big topic it's a bigger topic
than this particular story
this story is about the constant
self-incrimination of matt gates
possibly statutory rape and or
trafficking of a minor if indeed one of
the girls he met
he paid to have travel across state
lines and of course
the incredible double standard between
matt gates's membership and the supposed
party of family values
the republican party and this behavior
in conjunction with
many republicans continuing to defend
him now that being said
the number of republicans coming to matt
gates defense that number is shrinking
in number
uh almost daily now much of this is
being denied for now
a spokesperson for matt gates said to
cnn congressman gates has never paid for
sex
nor has he had sex with a 17 year old as
an adult
we'll see one of the even crazier parts
is roger stone's involvement that's not
it's almost like a detail but it's
actually
crazy in a series of messages that were
exchanged over the
encrypted messaging app signal that the
daily beast obtained
greenberg wrote to stone if i get you
250 000
in bitcoin would that help or is this
not a financial matter
and roger stone replied i understand all
of this
and have taken it into consideration i
will know more in the next 24 hours
i cannot push too hard because of the
nonsense surrounding
pardons and then stone later wrote to
greenberg i hope
you are prepared to wire me two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
because i am feeling confident
presumably in being able to get
greenberg a pardon
the pardon did not happen so this story
does not appear to be going away anytime
soon
it seems to be getting worse and worse
for matt gates
i think gates has benefited hugely in a
sense
gates has benefited from joe biden
getting so many things done that the
right-wing media
attention and media attention in general
has been on a lot of right-wingers
trying to find any way to attack joe
biden and it's pulled attention away
from matt gates
i expect the tension to get back to matt
gates maybe this week maybe next week
and i don't expect things to go
particularly well for him we'll have
more coverage of this
on our instagram page follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
we have much more coming up today one of
our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 percent off a high
quality wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman